50 مترا تحت سطح الماء النزول الى هذا
العمق دون معدات خاصه يعني الهلاك لمعظم
البشر ضغط هائل من الماء يؤدي الى عواقب
وخيمه واحتمال كبير ان ينتهي بالوفاء لكن
هذا الرجل يتحدى قوانين الطبيعه ويغطس
عميقا في المياه المتجمده بلا اي معدات
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منه
عالم غريب
بحث
ثلاثه تحديات قله من البشر يغدرون على
مواجهتها نقص الاكسجين والضغط المائي
والبروده الشديده حفره في طبقه من الجليد
في بحيره سويسريه متجمده خبط فينكل من
خلالها بعدما كتم انفاسه وغاص عموديا في
درجه حراره وصلت الى درجه مئويه واحده فقط
ولنحو 52 مترا من دون اي بدله غطس او
معدات فينكل البالغ من العمر 40 عاما داخل
موسوعه غينيس للارقام القياسيه لانجازه
الفريق حيث استطاع ان يستعيد ملصقا ثبت
اسفل المياه لاثبات انجازه ووسط حضور صحفي
واحتفاء اعلامي خرج من المياه محتفلا
بانجازه بعد ان استغرق للغطس والعوده
دقيقه و54 ثانيه فقط
بالنسبه للانسان العادي يمكن ان يتسبب
الغوص الى اعماق كبيره من دون معدات بتاذي
الانسجه المجاوره للاجواف الهوائيه في
الجسم كالجيوب الانفيه والاذنين والرئتين
وتسمى هذه الاصابه ارادت الضغطي وعند
الصعود الى اعلى سيتناقص ضغط الماء ويتمدد
الهواء داخل الرئتين ما قد يسبب تمزق
الحويصلات الهوائيه في الرئتين وصعوبه في
التنفس وفي حال دخول فقاعات هوائيه الى
الشرايين يتسبب ذلك في انسداد قد يؤثر في
اعضاء الجسم ويسمى الانصمام الغازي
الشرياني وتبعا لمكان وجود الفقاعات قد
تحدث نوبه قلبيه او سكته دماغيه
تحسبا لحدوث ايه مضاعفات للغواص فينكل
احيط لحظه خروجه بالمسعفين وعمال الطوارئ
للاطمئنان عليه بسق بعض الدماء من فمه
نتيجه التغير في مستويات الضغط اسفل
المياه لكنه خضع لفحوصات اجراها لاحقا في
المستشفى اظهرت انه لا يعاني من شيء خطير
لم تكن هذه المغامره الوحيده لفينكل اسفل
الجليد ففي عام 2021 قام الغواص التشيكي
بالسباحه تحت الجديد لنحو 81 مترا محطما
الرقم القياسي السابق البالغ نحو 76 مترا
والمسجله باسم السباح الدنماركي ستيج افال
رياضه الغوص والسباحه اسفل الجليد تنطوي
على خطوره كبيره لكنها ورغم ذلك لها محبون
كثر سجلت اسماؤهم في موسوعات الارقام
القياسيه